on en vient à la guerre en Ukraine le
président zellenski de nouveau près du
front il s'est rendu dans la zone de
barmut et puis centres des combats
depuis l'été dernier il se dit honoré de
pouvoir décorer ses héros Gulliver crack
où on vous retrouve en direct de Kiev si
je ne me trompe pas ce n'est pas la
première fois que le président Zelenski
se rend dans cette région stratégique
non le président
de l'invasion à grande échelle s'est
rendu à plusieurs reprises des endroits
les plus chauds c'est clairement quelque
chose qu'il considère
remonte le moral des Ukrainiens fait un
contraste avec Vladimir Poutine qui
s'est rendu une seule fois près de la
ligne de front en Ukraine et même pas
très près il s'est rendu à Mario Paul
sous couvert de la nuit dans des
circonstances vraiment beaucoup plus
sombre et avec beaucoup plus de mise en
scène on a l'impression que les visites
volody merzelinski sur le front même si
aujourd'hui c'était plutôt un cadre très
formel il a donné des des prix des
remerciements à des soldats et les louer
pour leur courage en défendant cette
zone et cette ville de batmouth cela
intervient à un moment où le
gouvernement devenant des merzelinski
quelque peu de critiquer en tout cas il
y a un débat en Ukraine c'est assez vif
sur la nécessité ou non de défendre
batmout beaucoup de voix s'élèvent pour
dire que le coût en termes de vie humain
et en termes d'adminition et de matériel
de défendre cette ville coûte que coûte
alors qu'elle est quasiment encerclée
que par les forces russes et tout
simplement trop élevé mais cette visite
intervient aussi à un moment où selon
notamment les renseignements
britanniques les Russes seraient en
train peut-être de culminer dans le
offensif sur Batman l'intensité de leurs
attaques ces derniers jours selon les
Britanniques auraient baissé et certains
estiment que ils vont tout simplement
pas arriver à compléter cette
encerclement des forces ukrainiennes et
apprendre la ville donc en quelques
sortes cela aurait peut-être donné
raison à volody Mercedes qui en tout cas
lui il pourrait peut-être le penser les
Ukrainiens auront réussi à tenir batkout
mais au coût de la destruction totale de
la ville et d'un très grand nombre de
vies ukrainiennes les Ukrainiens ne
disent pas le nombre de soldats qu'ils
ont perdu dans cette bataille pour
batmouth mais tous soldats et tous les
observateurs estiment que ça a été
vraiment été une bataille extrêmement
sanglante et avec un coup très très
élevé pour les deux côtés mais
symboliquement certainement si l'Ukraine
sera arrivé à même pas perdre patmout
avant de lancer sa contre-offensif qui
est attendu au printemps l'Ukraine va
considérer cela comme un grand succès
mais certains pensent que le coût de
cette défense de backmouth pourrait
avoir un impact sur le succès et la
réussite de la contre-offensif les
semaines qui viendront nous dirons
merci